so despite being a very avid spark user
today's demo which admittedly depends on
the Wi-Fi working so we may skip the
demo but will will at least try it
actually runs on top of Apache flink
rather than that patchy spark are there
any Apache flink users okay less than I
would expect for Berlin but that's
that's totally fine yeah you pretty much
covered all of this the only thing which
is is maybe different is I started doing
some code review live streams and you're
not in the contributing to open source
talk but if you are interested in sort
of seeing how a large project like
apache spark does its code reviews you
can you can watch these live streams and
hopefully it makes our github comments a
little more personal yeah and i've
worked at a bunch of places they're all
nice they all paid me money I've written
several books high-performance spark is
the new book it is probably not relevant
for this audience particularly but that
should not stop you from buying it the
royalties on it are much higher than the
other one so if you have a corporate
credit card it's a great way to give me
money in addition to Who I am
professionally I'm trans queer Canadian
I work in America on a work visa that
they're debating taking away which is
lots of fun and part of the leather
community and this is not particularly
relevant to training machine learning
models but I think it is useful to
remember that we all come from different
backgrounds and we should try and be
inclusive of people otherwise we're just
gonna build really shitty models and
reinforce our existing stereotypes and
biases and everything will go to [ __ ]
and it'll be our fault and I don't want
it to be my fault so don't do that okay
so hopefully you're nice people if you
mind pictures of cats this is not the
talk for you and you don't you don't
have to be familiar with spark or
I'll talk about them in detail so
tensorflow on spark with apache arrow is
demo number two that demo can sort of
run locally sometimes I have Python and
go on beam the go prototype works
slightly more reliably because it does
less things but the the fun feature prep
stuff is all in Python but I want to be
clear the stuff that I'm going to show
you today is not ready for production
use do not use this in production it
will go poorly to reinforce that really
don't use this in production it will go
really poorly I probably should have
updated that to June 8th I made this
slide yesterday but you get the idea
this will not for the wonderful folks
listening on the cording necessarily be
true indefinitely hopefully we we do fix
our undocumented features but you know a
check before you run this for for real
so I'm gonna talk about how we enable
non JVM support in beam this is
important because tensorflow and a lot
of the cool stuff that we want to do is
in Python but beam itself is written in
Java I will try and show you a TF
transform demo feeling that we can go
through the log files of a demo which I
ran when the Wi-Fi was working a little
better ok okay I'm gonna apparently
connect to a different Wi-Fi network for
the demo and please don't all connect to
that same Wi-Fi network anyways and if
there's time there's some other things
that I can go into that are pretty fun
too in my opinion
umm so why do we need to do this right
if you if you listen to perhaps some
deep learning talks you're like oh it's
magic
I just put tensorflow on my data and out
will come venture capital money and like
insights
and that's certainly half true in San
Francisco you can slap deep-learning on
pretty much anything and receive venture
capital but um even if you're like doing
amnesty at CSV you probably need to do
some form of feature prep and there's a
really good chance that if you're
actually a good use case for deep
learning your data probably doesn't fit
on a single machine if it does there's a
chance that you may not be a great use
case for for deep learning and so even
if you want to read some VC money it's
better if you have a large proprietary
data set and it's better if your
software works it's a lot easier to you
know get them to give you money when
your stuff works and to do that we have
to transform our raw features into kind
of useful things and so tensorflow on
its own doesn't have a lot of really
awesome tools for feature prep but
there's a bunch of cool tools built
around tensorflow in the ecosystem to do
feature prep in a way that we can also
do this at serving time TF transform and
and TF MA and TF serving work together
there's a wonderful package called cube
flow it doesn't work with any of the
things I'm showing you today but it
might in the future and the alternative
to this is to write giant piles of
custom Python code to do our future prep
doing things like recreating computing
the mean over some data and computing
z-scores and all kinds of fun things
however you you probably don't want to
spend your time writing distributed
algorithms to compute these things
because they're not it's not a lot of
fun right much rather use a tool which
can do this for us
an open source tool of course but you
know and the other problem with the
giant pile of custom code is once we've
done that we also have to recreate it at
serving time so if I if I write a bunch
of custom code to do my future prep I
then have to write a bunch of custom
code to take my incoming features from
people that I'm trying to predict on and
and transfer
so that I can actually feed it to
tensorflow and this often results in
copypasta code which is really great for
job security except when you forget to
update your copy and paste code and you
start predicting really bad things I say
this as someone who has definitely not
done that at this job but I've had a lot
of other jobs so traditionally you know
you write a custom feature prep in your
favorite big data tool mine is apache
spark but maybe yours is Apache beam or
desk or something like this you run it
on the prepared you run it you train on
there you're prepared data and then you
go into model serving and you're like oh
yeah okay I guess I need to to transform
everything and you do this and it's
error-prone and sad so yeah what the
magic will save us yay
so TF transform is kind of cool it
allows us to pre-process our data in a
number of ways and it also integrates
nicely into the existing tensor flow
model serving tools it's open source
it's not perfect and please please do
not use this in production unless you
happen to be running on GCP with
dataflow this on top of Lync which is
what we're going to talk about today is
garbage but getting better okay so what
does what does this look like our very
fancy feature prep stage we we might
want to Center some features scale some
things into a zero one range
encode strings two integers all kinds of
exciting things code that you probably
could write very easily but there's no
real reason for you to bother writing it
and what happens is we we can take this
and TF transform will fit all of these
things and produce constant tensors and
so it does a full pass over our training
data and produces constant
transformations which are then used at
serving time
so take thing add data receive magic yay
okay um and there's a whole bunch of
other things that we can do in there -
everyone loves engrams we can pretend
that that's the great way of handling
text that does not integrate with Spacey
today it probably should but ethers
there's lots of fun things that we can
we can do inside of here and you can add
more things into it it's just a pain in
the ass okay yeah
so how how do we get this to work
TF transform is written in Python but
beam which is the layer it runs on top
of is written in Java and the TLDR is we
use gr PC and protobuf that's not
particularly important but essentially
you can think of it as we just copy data
around a lot and if your traditional big
data user that might not be so
surprising but if you're coming from
maybe more of an HPC background you
might be like why are you copying these
buffers all of the time and it's because
formats are hard also apparently so is
Python the three we still require Python
to seven but if anyone wants to come and
have the delightful if you missed out on
the experience of modernizing a Python
to seven project because you were you
know in grad school or something you can
come and join us and relive that
wonderful experience and help us
modernize a delightful codebase and it's
it's it's getting there there's there's
a bunch of people working on making it
work with Python 3 and we will probably
finish it within the year and a half
like probably ok so how does this work
we have this portability framework which
allows arbitrary execution to happen and
this essentially spins up docker
containers and does IPC into the docker
containers and this is nice because if
you're coming from the SPARC world you
have this wonderful thing where it tends
to spin up
directly on the metal and then you have
whichever Python happens to be installed
on that machine with whatever libraries
happened to be installed on that machine
and that tends to go poorly especially
for people who are trying to use things
like like tensorflow
where you like really want to have nice
compiled versions there are a bunch of
opportunities for improvement here I
believe is what it would say in the
performance review for beam and right
now essentially you have to put your
permissions inside of your docker file
which is not good but we'll fix that for
sure okay so what does this quality
design look like we have our magic
portability layer and python can talk to
us and so can go
are there any go users in the audience
today oh I have a demo for two people um
and and Java of course talks to us and
beam is the common SDK and it can
compile down essentially into running on
top of Google clouds dataflow and
recently it finally started working it
can run on top of Lync which is cool
because then you don't have to give me
money you can just use open source
software and and not be locked in and in
the future we're totally probably going
to support spark but right now the main
thing that we support in spark is Zig
volts so working on that so so how does
this all relate to tensor flow tensor
flow is in Python um kind of it actually
calls a bunch of native code and once we
finish this SDK you can use this easily
in practice we can use it today with a
lot of pain and in theory we can reuse
our data prep code more easily the only
catch is if you have some really custom
business logic inside of your data prep
that's going to be kind of annoying for
us to get to work whew so we're gonna
pick an example the Chicago taxi data
example is the one which runs the other
example crashes and so this is
example that we're going to try and run
it does a bunch of string to int and
bucket heisting and some z-score
transformations on our wonderful data
and so we're gonna try and run this and
based on my testing yesterday there's a
one in three chance that this will be an
excellent opportunity for me to reboot
and do QA when it crashes I'm hoping
that's not the case today and to be
clear this is a fork of a fork of a fork
running on top of a master branch of
some software none of this stuff is
released you can totally go and do this
yourself but if you do good luck oh cool
so I have my job server running let's
see if the I'm on my let's see if I can
talk to the Internet
pinging Google calm okay oh that looks
great
sure maybe it'll work so we're gonna run
this pre process oh I'm on this one yeah
that's okay
glorious employer provides oh it's
recorded oh hi boss um anyways so we're
gonna we're gonna start actually let's
let's not put oh [ __ ] okay let's okay
let's go to hell - ff4 and okay so it is
running pre-processed up high which is
that that wonderful Python code I just
showed you ignore the deprecation
warnings they were just there for to
keep it exciting and it's it's so it's
kicked off the job I think maybe no it
hasn't kicked off the job that's not
good okay
whoo okay cool let's run this without
redirecting it yeah okay um so yeah it
reads and writes from a Google Cloud
Storage bucket it does this because I
don't have HDFS running on my on my
local node and this is the part which
requires the Internet unfortunately
ignore the CPU instruction warning
that's also just for to keep it exciting
and we can see it's creating it's sort
of initial graph this part normally
finishes faster oh okay oh yay okay so
it's it's done its first part it's
written out some some temporary models
and this this just is the the model
without them being fit so it doesn't
have the constant tensors yet it's it's
the tensors which reference the
transformations which are going to
happen yeah so this is really exciting
to watch for sure and soon it will kick
off a beam job
however this this might be a demo that
we whoo okay okay ah no it's not gonna
do anything yet okay this can be a demo
that we return to as ooh okay it's it's
sorry I I have that optimism that's
required to be a program where you're
like well maybe maybe this time right
and eventually it's true and you
remember that one time that it worked
and and that's what keeps you going
especially when you work on high-quality
open-source software in Python 2 7 um ok
oh so so the question is do I have some
advice for people who get criticized for
still using Python 2/7 and I would say
appeal to Authority and claim that
Google still uses Python 2 7 therefore
it's okay for you this is clearly a bad
idea but assuming the person you wish to
convince of your terrible idea is not in
this room they might believe you the
alternative is you should stop using
Python 2 7 because it's painful so right
what's happening now is while the darker
files have all of the dependencies that
we want installed in them it doesn't
have our job inside of it so it's taking
all of the sort of Python code for our
job and packaging it up into into a tar
file and shipping it across to our good
friend the job server who has started
running yay I thank God
ok that was going to be super awkward um
and we can see it's actually it did a
string to empath [ __ ] so it did it
string the ink conversion it did the
scale to z-score transformation we can
read this log and see all kinds of fun
things that it'sit's done on our data
there's a bug where I don't get standard
out in the other process all of the time
so everyone loves reading log files
admitted by a Java process they're
notoriously not verbose and so anyways
we can see that it's it's done what
we've asked it to do and that's kind of
cool and while we could wait for it to
save the resulting model back to GS
while the timer is no longer running on
this screen I suspect that might take a
while based on the Wi-Fi so we're gonna
transition away from this demo which is
definitely not crashed yet and and yeah
keep going okay cool um I
oh oh we took out the go demo I'm so
sorry
if the to go users and the audience want
to come find me later I am wearing a
pink dinosaur dress and and can show you
a demo of something similar and go so
now that you've done this right you you
fit you're you're happy TFM a model how
do we make this work so if you want to
use tensorflow serving or any of the
building tools the nice thing is this
outputted proper tensorflow so you can
just use it with TF serving if you've
written your own high-quality custom
serving layer you have an exciting
opportunity to reimplemented bunch of
code there's there's a guide that goes
into a lot more detail than this demo
did and the slides it's not focused on
running on open source but if you change
all of the places where it says data
flow to flink it kind of runs and so you
can you can oh you can't see the link I
will post the slides to my Twitter and
then you can click on this link because
that's I should have put the link text
here and my Twitter is holding Cairo and
and the slides will be there oh yeah
okay
optional second beam demo time who wants
to hang around for five minutes while we
run word count cool we're I'm sorry
we're gonna skip demo number two and
just roll with it okay so sometimes when
I talk to people about how stuff like
this works they're like wow that's a
really terrible design of Alden I should
not use this software what should I use
instead and I want to assure you
everything else is garbage too so
different trade-offs possibly better for
you possibly not let's look at some of
the other things that we do to
accomplish similar tasks of running
Python code and Big Data ecosystem
how many PI spark users are in the
audience okay keep your hands up if your
PI spark code if your PI spark error
messages make sense is there any one
okay Oh
one person good luck I hope that keeps
working and so PI spark doesn't use your
PC and protobuf it uses different things
we use pickling sockets pipes and JSON
and I don't have a funny image for JSON
Jason's not funny but at least it's not
XML so we can run similar things whoo I
have the timer back that's wonderful so
PI spark also allows us to run Python
code and we can run similar things on
top of pi spark in addition the it's the
same technique used for supporting other
languages on SPARC just as in beam where
it go is supported they just pick
different languages to bother supporting
it's fairly mature it has a lot of
performance hurdles from the design I
want to assure you we have fixed none of
those in beam so it doesn't get any
better but we did fix some of the
dependency issues so that's cool and
this this high-quality design looks like
Python talking to Java talking to Java
talking to Python and you can really
feel this when you get an exception
you'll get a Python stack trace wrapped
in that Java stack trace wrapped in a
Java stack trace wrapped in a Python
stack trace and you may get two times
the number of workers that you have
copies of that stack trace yay um so
yeah if that demo had failed thankfully
I'm running it on one worker my laptop
we would have only gotten one error
message but if I was running it on a
real cluster I would have gotten
hundreds I'm not sure that helps um
don't end flink follows the same pattern
and so we can see that that pretty much
everyone was just like wow
that looks like a good idea let's copy
that without
thinking about it and we've excitingly
recreated the same mistakes for about
ten years in a row and so everything
gets kind of more expensive the error
messages make no sense and dependency
management really doesn't work in in
Pais part unfortunately
thankfully this is one of the things
that we fixed in beam we were like oh
the the one example that I want to run
is tensorflow
and my machines don't have tensorflow
installed on them I should fix that and
so it lets you have this nice docker
file and you just install all of your
dependencies and I forgot to use the
nice compiled version of tensorflow but
you totally could use versions which are
targeted for your machines and all those
other things are less important which is
why they're not colored in red and yes
we can also run tensorflow on spark yay
and yeah we can run em inist whoo or as
I like to call it the hello world of big
data sorry no the hell it it is the
hello world of tensorflow
which is the word count of big data and
so yes yeah okay um so surprisingly this
actually works like there's a whole pile
of code that uses hidden behind the
scenes but this is a part of code that
you would have to write yourself if you
run this you might be like wow this is
kind of slow I wonder if it's going to
get better and the answer is kind of and
khuda' sorry Hey Apache arrow is a
really cool project which supports a
whole bunch of different platforms
including CUDA but more importantly for
us including the JVM and Python and it
gives us a consistent data format that
we can actually share between each other
rather than rewriting our data into
different formats every time we have to
switch between one of these systems and
actually so some of the performance work
that people were doing in spark showed
that for some jobs we ax
we spend more time changing the data
between formats than the actual work and
especially if you're computing
relatively simple things like means and
Z scalar transforms you're gonna spend
more of your time just serializing data
into different formats and so the PDF
version of these slides
this isn't animated but the the galaxies
here are supposed to be going by really
quickly like data moving really quickly
so there's a really well thought out one
so just pretend that this is animated or
or look at the slides later okay and
there's this vendor benchmark from a
vendor that I no longer work for um that
implies this could be 242 times faster
oh my god that is a lie
I'm sorry this is recorded by a lie what
I meant is careful selection of facts
and yes it could be 242 times faster
under very very specific circumstances
more likely you might see a 50% speed up
that's nowhere near 242 times but that's
still pretty good 50% is is worth
rewriting my code into a way that I
can't understand anymore
and so this is the arrow diagram kind of
and we can see Java and Python and R and
even CUDA can talk to it
and it can also talk to data formats so
it can read in park' files and if you
want to just entirely skip spark or beam
you could provided that your data fit in
memory at which point you probably don't
need big data you should probably get
your data out of Parque and saved into a
local format that's useful but I'm not
telling you your data is not big I know
people get very upset about that you've
already bought your class
so we can just ignore that part for now
so how do we rewrite our code to use
this so spark catalog register function
adding numbers this is definitely a
thing that we want to do in Python
because numeric computation in Java so
definitely adding integers this is the
place to do it and we use pandas UDF and
this looks pretty similar right
admittedly this example was picked so
that it looked really similar but this
this is promising
and we can actually do this inside of
tensorflow on spark the main magic that
happens is this really sort of gnarly
for each partition and we're gonna
rewrite this in to use the new happy
arrow path rather than the old RDD path
and so what we do is our do train
function becomes a pentose UDF that
returns integers because we forgot to
support returning null and so we were
just returned a lot of zeros will we'll
fix that later
and the sad hack for now is probably the
one part of the code which will survive
just based on my personal experience and
we we just put our our map function
inside of here and we call train
function this this is really simple
relative to to the complexity of making
TF on spark work just hacking in support
for the pandas UDF is pretty oh sorry
bye pandas UDF I mean arrow
we call them pandas UDF's because the
objects that you interact with in PI
spark look like pandas dataframes
or series as the case may be and so we
get our data across the wire a lot
faster and now this looks like this yeah
Java to arrow to Python that's a
tensorflow kind of on by kinda I mean
provided that your cluster has no nodes
crash Walid's doing this step it's
totally fine
and if it crashes just try again so it's
that well try catch you know just wait
for this code to work thing and that's
because the scheduler and spark make
some assumptions and tensorflow makes
some assumptions and those assumptions
are very different and we're working on
fixing that but it's probably not going
to happen in time for you to run this
code so definitely well try catch and no
sorry except I spent too much time in
Java and I'm very sorry and and then
just wait for the code to succeed so
there's there's some things that we
could do we could avoid copying this
data into Python we could we could set
up our graph in Python and then just
copy the data directly from the JVM into
tensorflow
and that would give us some cool
performance benefits the downside is I
would have to write a lot of Java code
or someone here could write a lot of
Java code if there's any like closet
Java developers in the audience just
come talk to me I have a bunch of cool
projects for you to do that I don't want
to and and you can fix this to go even
faster there's a whole bunch of
references if you're oh ok yeah here
here are the links that I was talking
about earlier you can look at the
example guide if you want to go play
with Apache beam and check out the
master example and try and use this on
your own data you can totally do that if
you're more of a spark user and you want
to use tensorflow on spark that's the
version there and you can do the hacks
that I showed you earlier and there's a
whole bunch of other fun things and I
have 2 minutes and 49 seconds so I'm
going to say key thanks bye
[Music]
let's see if the demo finished um
[Music]
what's not okay uh yeah does anyone have
questions for me or I also have bonus
slides if anyone really loves slides we
can go look at more slides so thanks for
the great
yeah okay thanks for the great talk I
was wondering is any of these things
better with desk because it seems like
having the extra Java layer makes it you
know a little bit more difficult in some
ways that is perhaps what one could
describe as an understatement um and
yeah the the extra layer of Java just
doesn't add a lot um except for stack
traces I mean so so more seriously the
the main thing that that Java adds in
these cases is the ability to interact
with the rest of the Big Data ecosystem
so if I want to pull my data out of hive
if I want to run on top of yarr and if I
want to be scheduled against some other
things it's it's kind of useful but yeah
if you have a pure Python thing that
only needs to interact with other Python
things desk is probably a lot less
painful sorry
recording people but yes
can I ask a really noob question when
does it make sense to start using you
know these sophisticated technologies
rather than just running on my local
machine and kind of waiting for days and
feels that folks
it's totally not something I do yes okay
so I see there is sarcasm in Germany as
well so that's lovely yes I would say at
the point that you're waiting for days
is probably an excellent opportunity to
parallelize your work really I
personally do the cut over at the point
that my data and no longer fits in
memory or it takes like more than the
amount of time I think I'm gonna spend
debugging the distributed system to run
which is because I'm an optimist and
like most an hour to divide my
distributed problems
it's never the case but if it's if it's
taking like a whole afternoon I think
that's a good opportunity to to rewrite
your code normally it's not too gnarly
to rewrite on top of a distributed
system and if it if it is you know just
buy a bigger computer or rent one from
Google Cloud quantum one maybe we I
don't keep up to date with our product
announcements and but definitely I'm
sure whatever we sell is great and you
should buy it
[Applause]